(gentle music)
- [Newscaster] These satellite images
show an ammunition depot
in the Russian-occupied parts
of Ukraine's Kherson region
in May and in mid-June 2023.
This attack is one of a number
of Ukrainian strikes on
Russian military infrastructure
and supply lines in recent weeks.
(gun firing)
As Ukraine continues the
push to take back territory,
Kyiv has been using
British long-range missiles
in an attempt to degrade Russia's ability
to defend the areas it occupies.
Here's a closer look at the strategy
and the role of Western weapons.
(suspenseful music)
In late June, Ukrainian
missiles struck a bridge
linking the occupied Crimean Peninsula
to the Russian-controlled
parts of the Kherson region,
Russian and occupation officials said.
This bridge played a key role
in supplying Russia's frontline troops
in the south of Ukraine via Crimea.
British intelligence said
the route's temporary closure
doubled the length of time it took
for Russian logistics convoys
to reach the front lines.
The Russian-appointed
head of the Kherson region
dismissed the significance of the attack.
Russian state media reported
that rocket fragments indicated
the bridge was hit with Storm
Shadow missiles from the UK.
Ukraine's stepped up strikes
against infrastructure
deep in Russian-occupied territory,
came after London provided it
with long-range missiles in May.
(Volodymyr Zelensky speaking
in foreign language)
- [Newscaster] The missiles
are fired from aircraft
and have a range exceeding 155 miles,
enough to hit Russian
logistics hubs and bases.
(missile blasting)
This is dramatically beyond
the reach of HIMARS launchers
sent by the US to Ukraine,
which were modified to keep their range
within about 50 miles.
Last year, Kyiv
successfully used the tactic
of targeting Russian
supply lines with HIMARS
to retake the city of Kherson.
However, Kherson was uniquely vulnerable
because Russian troops there
could only be resupplied over bridges.
The Ukrainian and Russian
Ministries of Defense
didn't respond to a request for comments
on the significance of the
recent Ukrainian attacks
and the role of long-range missiles.
Britain's Defense Secretary
speaking of the use of Storm
Shadow missiles in Ukraine,
urged Kyiv's Western allies
to provide more long-range equipments.
- I think the key here
is to recognize that
if the Russians move out of range,
we must work together, internationally,
to make sure that the equipment is given
to make sure they're back in range.
- [Newscaster] In late June,
American and European officials
said the US was considering approving
a long-range missile system for Ukraine.
In the meantime, these
attacks show Ukraine's focus
on destroying the support
system for Russian troops,
while trying to preserve
troops and Western tanks.
(gentle music)
(wind buffeting)